all right nico's outside right now with
the node crew we're gonna go kick the
soccer ball at him
blowing up the beach ball that already
makes you light-headed so giant soccer
ball i almost passed out
[Music]
i can't open the door anymore
just like when a man conquers mount
everest
we ask him why i think that's why we got
that giant soccer ball out that day
[Music]
was like this is the giant soccer ball
and the door came up and you can see it
rolling down the stairs this is a huge
ball gotta keep my pokemon kicking in
there while we're playing make sure i
get all these steps don't want to waste
them no b corridor first of all those
guys making all those videos over there
talking about us taking sam and nico
from us i've had it but other than that
generally it was i thought it was very
important that the guys just stay fit
you know
goalies right no goalies
[Music]
when i first kicked that ball i was not
expecting it to feel like i was kicking
an elephant
[Music]
playing normal soccer
it hurts my body
don't exercise enough giant soccer hurts
way more
[Music]
yeah if they act like a team and like
pass to each other but they're literally
just head butting back and forth it's
like no like oh propeller down the field
like they're all trying to showcase yeah
it's not just like who's stronger it's
like come on
[Music]
so pokemon go came out like four days
ago on friday sam was in iceland when it
came out now he's back sam came back to
almost being like level 10s 11s and like
sam you gotta get this game asap he's
like you guys are crazy and then he
played the game he's like nope just
kidding we're all crazy crazy about
pokemon and i'm already crazy about
pokemon i mean we just ran a freaking
three month long d uh pokemon game yeah
coming up with ideas for pokemon go
video like i don't want to be this into
a game that everyone else is into just
like the hipster inside of me have you
not played it yet dude i play it so much
[Music]
our michael
he uh you know was getting into the game
[Music]
he got a little bit too into it
most importantly
i'm glad he was all right you know that
was a nice surprise
[Music]
i may have gotten a little overzealous
when
the goal happened
[Music]
i think the fact that carmichael jumped
in with me during that time really made
it
carmichael has to go to a dinner and now
he's covered in schmidt so that's great
it's so big you can't see if somebody's
on the other side of it you go to kick
it but there's a hesitation that at any
second it could just like explode into
your face because somebody else might
kick it right there
[Music]
one come on you guys come on
next one wins all right
i was hoping that it was caught on
camera so it could make for a good
highlight
next time first person to get a goal
[Music]
because other than that i would have
no
no justification for taking a hit like
that
i want a shootout
if they took the goal post and they
opened them up so that it was just if
you get past the line someone would
score a point the goal is now the entire
line trades with
[Music]
you know i'm glad i got wrecked once
there we go
[Music]
advantage
node wins this well i guess we need to
work on our soccer skills god damn i
miss everything
turns out it's really
really exhausting it's not expecting the
game to be that exhausting i think it
was all the jumping
oh it's so exhausting
i will avenge this
bloody mess
man
or war never changes
[Music]
i guess that shows you how much we want
to play giant soccer again
it's kind of sad
but not as sad as not subscribing to sam
nico
that's right
we put our necks on the line playing
giant soccer for you for your enjoyment
i think the least you can do is
subscribe
i'll wait
the rest you guys who are subscribed
you're cool you can go
but i want you
you unsubscriber right there watching
this right now
click that subscribe button
yeah oh if we play giant soccer against
rocket jump then we just slaughter them